[Music]  lock out of the NFL referee still  grinding on and the replacement refs  let's face it I think everyone agrees  it's a disaster okay everyone's talking  about how the refs  made a terrible call in last night's  game well I decided to watch a highlight  reel of replacement refs from this past  weekend and I want to share it with you  because I agree they're pretty bad all  right now you see how long you can do it  number 34 on the offense is on my  fantasy team  so touchdown I give that last play three  and a half footballs and I'll see you at  the movies  holding number 65 on the  down look I'm not drunk at all officer  come on I'm hilarious  before I give the ruling on the field I  want to take a minute to share the  wisdom of Scientology I didn't see the  play  holding offense I wanna swim with the  dolphins in the sea  everybody now a big at the die to make  one of these  [Applause]  you  [Applause]